mike myers shares the fatherhood advice  he received from adam sandler  yes comedian to comedian the two shared  a heartwarming conversation over the  phone and adam told mike to spend all  the time he can with his kids mike  shared the details while talking to  jessica and julia cunningham on sirius  xm's the jess cagle show check this out  he just called me out of the blue and  said i heard you're about to have kids  and he said um i'm very happy for you  and kelly he said do you know that  feeling you have when you're uh 12 years  old you fall in love for the first time  your ribs ache he said that's what it's  going to be like every day he said it's  going to be like finding out that  there's a room in your house that you  didn't know but you realize that it's a  part of your heart and i was like oh my  god adam that is like  the greatest thing ever and he said  spend time with your kids dude it goes  by very very fast